un chanteur volant dans une drôle de
machine à la souchon qui pourtant n'aime
pas l'avion a battu un record du monde
en traversant la manche en 1h20 sur un
petit appareil qui pèse moins de 500 kg
et qui a l'air de voler à l'envers il
est vrai que son co pilote était un vrai
professionnel habitué à des engins
beaucoup plus encombrant points à 2 180
kg vitesse 300 km heure sur cet avion de
construction amateur les instruments
sont alimentés par des piles solaires et
c'est avec cet appareil pour le moins
étrange qu'alain souchon les gérard
feldzer pilote 747 et air france ont
choisi d'établir ce record londres paris
ça vous amuse vous aimez beaucoup
piloter je suis je prends l'avion
d'accord alors ces tensions d'un projet
pilote pour m'habituer
j'ai rencontré gérard il ya quelques
temps
d'accord mais qu'est ce que c'est
exactement peu importe cela record du
monde
décollage de biggie lille près de
londres un membre éminent de la
fédération aéronautique était présent
pour contrôler et homologuer ce record
répondez-moi la pression là aussi le
vide que tu as fait
l'entente bakool beaucoup sont là parce
que sur la période de vents forts
leur accord apprentis à l'état brut sans
gagner plus
ce nouveau levier peut marquer dans le
temps
je voudrais pas les chars d une chanson
à la hausse
je suis je
c'est la partie que nous attendons tous
et je suis souvent mal chez eux et ça
marche
marc commencer